but you have to have that testing and
you have to have that testing on a scale
right you have 19 million people in the
state of New York just think of how many
people you would need to be able to test
and test quickly so the antibody testing
is part of that also rapid testing to
determine whether or not you have the
virus now exists they have four
15-minute tests that are commercially
available but again they have to be
brought to scale no private company has
the capacity to bring those to scale so
speaking with governor Murphy and
governor Lamont we are interested in
working with private companies that can
actually in bring this testing capacity
to scale and to scale quickly because
again if you have the antibody testing
that's part if you can then test if a
person is positive for the virus and you
can do it that day and you can get those
results in 15 minutes that's also
another way to get back to life and do
it quickly so we're very interested in
that New York so is New Jersey so is
Connecticut these there are private
companies that have these tests again
it's all up to scale we're starting them
in the state of New York but we only
have about a 50,000 person testing
capacity which is nice but it's not of a
scale that's actually going to make a
large difference so private companies
that are interested in getting into this
space and coming up to scale quickly we
are interested in those companies and
we're interested in investing in those
companies and they should contact us at
Empire State Development Corporation the
also restarting life the state budget
not just this state but every state
budget has been decimated by the
situation and shut down the economy
people aren't working they're not paying
income taxes business
aren't operating so our budget just
collapsed right our revenues just
collapsed you want to restart the
economy you have to help restart the
local governments and that's going to be
a federal act I don't have the capacity
as a governor no governor does to
generate revenue in a positive way from
an economy that's not operating that is
going to be a federal stimulus bill
there's no other way to do this and it
has to be a stimulus bill that actually
understands you have state and local
governments that have to be brought up
to speed and functioning if you want to
facilitate this restarting of the
economy federal government passed some
legislation as I've said at the time it
was woefully inadequate from New York's
point of view we then have had some time
to actually study the legislation it
actually gets worse when you read it and
it's not even what was represented to us
initially so I'm sending our
congressional delegation a letter today
saying the passed legislation did good
for the nation I have no doubt gave aid
to a lot of people in places that needed
it but it was not fair
to New York and that has to be remedied
in any legislation that goes forward the
last point I know it's been a
frustrating 37 days but it's only been
37 days on the other hand I know if she
was like a lifetime it's been so
disruptive so we'll brought so
frightening so disorienting but it's
only been 37 days right everything in
context and everything in perspective I
know it's tough to get up every day and
this is like Groundhog Day living
through this bizarre reality that
worried it's even more difficult I think
with the weather changing and you feel
the seasons changing and it's
nicer and you start to open a new book
of possibilities and you know now the
weather's getting nice and I should be
getting outdoors and I should be doing
this and I should be doing this I get it
but it's only been thirty seven days and
I started by saying those numbers of
cases that's not arbitrary what we do
affects the number of cases our behavior
affects the number of cases we're
generating the cases they're not
descending on us from heaven right it's
our behavior so it's been 37 days the
1918 pandemic that we talked about
peaked in New York for six months came
through in three waves and it peaked for
six months thirty thousand people died
in New York during that pandemic why
they didn't react the way we did they
didn't know as much as we know today
they didn't have the same drug therapies
but we are changing the curve in that in
that virus growth you see that
plateauing that's because of what we are
doing if we don't do what we are doing
that is a much different curve and
that's what happened in the past so
social distancing is working well you
shut down all the businesses I know well
you shut down all the schools I know but
it is working that's why you see those
numbers coming down if we were doing the
same rate of interaction those numbers
would still be going up so to the extent
we see a flattening or a possible
plateau that's because of what we are
doing and we have to keep doing it I
know it's hard but we have to keep doing
it and to the extent it takes
an effort remember at this time it's not
a it is about we and it is not about me
I know what I would like to be doing I
would like to be going its motorcycle
weather for me it's time to get out on
the water it's time to go hiking in the
Adirondacks I get it it's not about me
it's not about me what I do will affect
other people
it will affect my family it will affect
other people it will affect people in
those emergency rooms who are killing
themselves every day to keep other
people safe
I get infected I will affect them so we
all talk about society and community and
interconnection and inter relation and
family and life is bigger than us now is
the time to live that right now is the
time to live that so when you feel that
need I have to do this it's not about me
it's about we and what's good for all of
us and my health is in your hands and
your health is in my hands and the
health of those healthcare workers and
those first responders and all those
people who have to show up to work every
day to keep society functioning we are
responsible to them also so to the
extent it's hard I get it but maybe if
we think about it through a different
lens a broader lens it'll be a little
easier so let's not get complacent we
have to stay disciplined we have to stay
smart we have to stay safe and we do
that by staying at home and we will get
through that through this together
questions
the combinations and that we couldn't
place the lake publications in the small
number and even said that they're going
to be treating us small another occasion
but you know what you know will this
should be able to hear for yeah I spoke
to general Shaughnessy I spoke to the
president I spoke to the vice president
and I spoke to north well is helping
manage the Comfort when you transition
from non kovat patients to co vyd the
capacity of the ship goes from 1,000
beds down to 500 beds but it can treat
500 Kovac patients adequately and safely
and that's what we're transitioning into
operation now we have a test our
wodsworth lab that we have developed
we're working to scale that up now over
the course of the next week we'll be
able to figure out how many we can run
we're expecting to be able to scale that
up not just here in the lab in our lab
but to get other labs do as well that's
where we'll have to work with the FDA to
get that approved you have to look at
them some antibiotics measure the
immunoglobulin G and others measure the
immunoglobulin M ng the difference is
that some suggest that there's a new
infection occurring that's the IgM and
others show that the infections been
around for a while so it's important to
make sure that the tests that we are
measuring show that individuals have the
infection they aren't have the infection
and still still have the infection so
it's important to make sure it's the
correct test our test measures the
immunoglobulin she's saying that they
have the infection and it's resolved did
you get that thank you
so there's many tests that are out there
that companies are making there's two
types of immunoglobulins there's one
that says the infection just is still
there and you're starting to mount a
response which has happens with
virus and other your body also makes an
immunoglobulin after your infection has
is resolved or it's developed it's
resolved that's the one you want to
measure otherwise you may be measuring
something which actually says you still
have the infection in your body you want
to measure the I'm sure the is Borough
Park Brooklyn right
I'm sure the NYPD will be doing what
they need to do I made it clear
yesterday that these social distancing
regulations are not just please their
regulations you can be fine for it we
increase the fine to make the point that
was serious I'm sure the NYPD will be
enforcing it but also people have to
understand I understand religious
gatherings I understand the Orthodox
community Jewish Orthodox community I'm
very close to them and I have been for
many many years and my family is very
close to them but now is not the time
for large religious gatherings I mean
we've we paid this price already we've
learned this lesson that was New
Rochelle in Westchester so please now is
not the time you do know when you do
know when a service by making this worse
and infecting more people Joseph
there was a reports that communities of
color have been particularly hit hard by
the virus do you know that that's been
the case in New York a lot of data so
the hospitals actually don't report the
race information directly to the state
so what we end up doing on the backend
is calling the coroner's offices around
the state after the death has been
reported so there has been a lag we
understand people want that information
we want that information too and we'll
have it this week so one of the
challenges is that some of the
communities are have challenges with
their health in general they're more apt
to have some of the challenges with with
asthma and diabetes and so anytime
anyone who has underlying medical
conditions ends up with this virus and
the other virus that puts them more at
risk
there is progress there and we'll have
that new interface up and running by
Thursday and we've actually worked with
Verizon a lot of the problem was the the
lines we're crashing because the volume
was so extreme we've now moved 80% of
the incoming calls off of the Verizon
system and into call centers and so you
should start to see some easing up on
that today and again we just asked
people to remain patient as we get this
resolved the executive order on Friday
regarding ventilator redistribution and
I believe that that executive order was
also going to cover are there things
that still hasn't appeared is there a
reason for the delay no I'm going to
issue an executive order today on
everything that I've mentioned the fines
etc today that will cover everything
we've discussed to date it was always
the hospitals tell us what they have
quote-unquote
available meaning unused and they're not
going to use it in the foreseeable
future so it was always of the equipment
that you believe you Hospital believe is
available if if the state lent 20% of
the available units as you define
available that would be 500 and 500
ventilators was a big deal especially
two weeks ago frankly since then other
things have happened we have a thousand
ventilators from China California freed
up 500 ventilators Oregon sent 140
ventilators state of Washington freed up
I think 400 ventilators or something
like that we've also acquired an
additional 500 ventilators so we're not
in the position that we were in but
that's what it always was a hospital
says we have available by their own
definition unused inventory we're not
using for the foreseeable future 20
percent of that number
leaving them with 80% of the unused was
500 ventilators no that's forever saying
it's something that I think is going to
come up and I think it's an important
thing to look at I'd also like to find a
way to say thank you to these health
care workers who are out there every day
you know we talk to them on the
telephone but achieve what they have
done is just incredible just incredible
and not just the health care workers I
mean that health care workers just think
of the mindset walking to that ER every
morning putting on these gowns putting
on all this protective clothing having
to change the protective clothing
several times a day seeing people pass
away and then go home and deal with the
stress at home but also the first
responders the transit workers you look
at the rates of sickness I mean they
know what they're exposing themselves to
and they they still do it I mean just
god bless them
are just any inmates in the state prison
system - we're looking at that you know
any way we can we are and we're looking
at that continually I don't think
there's anything new on that right now
but it's something we're exploring all
the time we've done a number but nothing
right now are there no we've done about
700 parole violators statewide those are
people who were deemed to be low risk to
the public safety and also high risk
took Ovid and so we have done that so
far and we're continuing to evaluate it
on an ongoing basis the promise was
about 400 people to come out of Riker's
so far that's been about a hundred and
thirty people have been released is
there reasonable are 240 out of Riker's
so far of the 700 stay by but we can get
you the exact numbers and Governor on a
more kind of psychological philosophical
issue 730 people died these numbers keep
rolling out but they're it's easy it
would seem to get numb to these sorts of
you know stats how you counter that how
do you impress on people that these are
human lives that this is an enormous
human catastrophe you know Jesse if they
I hear the point I guess one could get
numb to the numbers that's why I said
remember every number is a human being
behind that and a family for myself I
can tell you the last thing I do is get
numb I can tell you for the hospital
staff that goes through this they're not
getting numb for the families who are
suffering they're not getting numb the
pain is increasing the grief is
increasing I mean you see those pictures
on TV of getting to a situation where
you have to put bodies in in trucks in
parking lots I mean how you could get
numb to any of this
I can I can't imagine
especially in New Yorkers that we lose
the humanity of this it's something I
struggle with everyday I try to think of
the opposite that you know we are doing
good because you can't stop you can't
stop you can't save everyone this virus
is very good at what it does and it
kills vulnerable people that's what it
does and it does that very well and we
can't stop that the question is are you
saving everyone you can save and there
the answer is yes and I take some solace
in that fact our healthcare system is
operating when I don't believe we lost a
single person because we couldn't
provide care people we lost we couldn't
save despite our best efforts but no I
don't I don't see I don't see the
numbness and I don't believe New Yorkers
see the numbness I think the frustration
of an individual situation can cause you
to do irresponsible things to go out to
go out more than you should to disregard
social distancing I think that's that's
an issue and that's what I've been
trying to address
don't know it's a good question I think
they go back as my opinion it's not a
fact I think and it's a we're working on
a plan with Connecticut and New Jersey
because when we go back we go back
together I think if we go back with
people who have tested that they are
negative or people who have tested that
they have the antibodies which means
they had the virus and they're immune
from the virus or we go back with
younger people going first still
protecting isolating the vulnerable but
if it's waves I think those are the
waves so they're usually when you have a
virus you develop antibodies you don't
get it again there was one report out of
China where they suggested that maybe
there were some cases but that hasn't
been confirmed yet
a significant number of patients know
they're ramping up now the Javits Center
and the Comfort you're talking about the
Javits in comfort well there's two
separate situations when I say we have
about 90,000 bed capacity we brought
online additional beds right two ways
number one every hospital had to
increase capacity by 50% with a goal of
a hundred percent every hospital is
increased capacity 50% that's why you
see hospital beds in conference rooms
and lobbies etc second we built
temporary emergency facilities primarily
primarily earlier on downstate New York
they may or may not be used depending on
whether or not we need the beds the
Javits and the Comfort we are using and
they're ramping up now I'm going to
speak to the hospitals thank you
grocery store workers transit workers
first responders police officers these
are all in my opinion heroes of today
because they get up every morning they
go to work so society stays safe and
functional and we're doing everything we
can to protect them but we owe them a
big thank you thank you guys